yellow welcome to a new video in the e55
repertoire series originally I had
intended to do this video about both
Ponciano opening this on the third move
here c3 the position that is on the
board and also I wanted to to show
something here about the form Knights
game but in the end I decided to split
this and do this video just on the
Pantheon II while this opening is some
very rarely encountered it's um it's I
don't know I think I played it only once
in the Turnagain game after a couple of
years of u45 experience and what to set
him to click it away yeah I only got it
once in the tournament game and I hadn't
really studied it before and I didn't
play the best way but when I equalized
quite easily so but the Pantheon II is
something you will rally get but it's
good to know the best line against it
because um
with this Black has really good chances
to even play for an advantage not just
equalizer
get an even position you can you can
play for fun advantage lots of the lines
the main add effect of this move here is
c3 is that it's very slow it doesn't
really put pressure on black and the
most important thing is it doesn't do
anything about the move T 75 if you look
at this position and consider the main
moves which would be Bishop c4 which
prevents d5 of course make very direct
fashion you've got the Spanish which
also prevents d5 as if five is hanging
at least and also if you look at not c3
this also prevents d5
and D for the Scotch yeah basically also
prevents d5 it has added a some opening
the center immediately and you cannot
get in d5 so easily so c3 it's no
surprise that the best move is d5 and
and this is a rather typical response to
a c3 move as after taking and the Queen
recaptures you won't get hit by 93 years
so this position is already fine for
black if white plays d4 now you have the
choice you can take on d4 and suppose to
the Nordic or Goering gambit what I did
in the last video just capture here or
you can even try to only exploit this
and omit this capture going for a long
castle immediately and black has to find
position also so this is not not the
idea actually White's idea is mostly
technical here he wants to yeah install
a pin now on the night and this can be
done by Queen a4 and Bishop b5 I think
I'll go with Bishop b5 first this is the
traditional mainline but it has got the
nicer what you hope like that it is
basically leading by force to black
advantage but you need to know your
theory here and also yeah be ready for
some some tactical battle so black takes
only for now
my phone is ringing well just ignored D
take C for now nine take C 5 and now of
course there's opinion on the c6 night
white threatens to capture and black
answers with a very direct move Queen to
g5 and yeah this is very very technical
now if the night let's let's start with
the simple moves this is the main move
white would capture here you would even
have the choice to take on g2 or just
captured b5 this is just just good for
black getting the bishop here and the
knight doesn't have a decent square but
queen g2 also would be possible
the main move here is Queen a form we
newing the spin but white might also
play d4 yeah covering the knight on e5
and also checking the Queen the capture
on g2 now the rook is hanging so why
doesn't have time really to to do
something on c6 rook f1 and now the very
nice move Bishop d6 this has the
technical point that if white captures
with the knight now you can play the
Knights move Bishop e7 pinning this
night it's it's really worth remembering
this kind of motive motive here to to
might use it in a game not actually in
this specific position but it's a nice
to know the idea and black is very good
here he destroyed white circle side
white can also go for a mousse like this
here attacking f7 but you can just go g6
Queen moves takes here
Bishop e7 and after night GE 7 and long
Castle black just has an easy game it's
got an extra pawn on top of all and also
an attack on the White King coming
because White's King doesn't have a
decent place he just lost his pawn and
has the rook on f1 it's just a silly
position so d4 isn't isn't really
playable at all well in fact the whole
line is not playable here but you need
to know your stuff because it gets were
really wild now Queen a4 what could also
capture here first and then Queen a
father's needs to the same position
let's just do it the other way around
Queen a form and now black doesn't take
on e5 or something but takes on g2 and
now it gets it gets funny white captures
on c6 he could also try a move like rook
f1 but then you go Bishop h3 this is the
whole point because now if the the
bishop on b5 leaves this position for
instance to take here then f1 the f1
rook is hanging and it doesn't have any
escape square so if if white Bishop h3
not King you want if white would take
here we would transpose to the main game
you will see this later and an
independent tribe would be something
like king D 1 and now for instance
Bishop d6 black is never afraid of the
capture here because white played rook
e1 in this example game if capture here
happens then at the end let's say let's
say this for instance he cannot take
here because this one is just hanging as
well and black has a deadly attack on
White's King he's just far better
developed I guess this is really close
to made already
so rook e1 and now black can
just sacrifice a PC and Knight f6 Knight
takes c6 and castles you do not have to
remember this stuff really you will
never get this on the bottommost likely
but it's useful to see the the attacking
scheme some applied here 94 c5 yeah you
can see black just has a huge attack h3
Bishop g3 and yeah white cannot save
that you want look this was actually
happened in a in a tournament game I
don't have the the names here written in
my my score but white resigned here
after 40 moves you see that this line
can be to really quick disaster
this was rook f1 in this position what
what usually takes him takes Queen takes
and now really important King d8 this is
a move you need to remember really
because you somehow I think this one
would would be a good idea but this
isn't so clear after Queen takes c7 here
so you need to go to d8 and you mustn't
be afraid of the capture on f7 this is
just not working because h1 is is
hanging with check and complete
destruction of the white position so may
move here is rook f1 but we can also
look briefly at this if you like King
here's the only move and now if white
for instance would try to take here you
can just take here King you too and now
it's just the matter of the most exact
execution here the first thing I didn't
really look at this before because it's
just losing but well that's check
quickly maybe this one here King needs
to go up and you can you can get the
King really far up here and I guess
there's a mate coming up somewhere I'm
not seeing it right now to be honest but
it should be should be
made maybe rue create well this is of
course it's just just not playable maybe
even even Queen f3 here and Bishop g4
this was also being made yeah well it's
not it's not possible to take on f7
white can take on a8 of course and this
leads to something like this takes and
now the very cool move Bishop d6 check
here King g7 Knight takes white cannot
take take here because of the coming
attack let's say Queen check here King
here and now move like Bishop a6 and he
too is just mate whites Queen is not
playing on 8 yeah either this is quite
funny stuff but you just need to be
confident that that is winning in this
really is and you need to work your way
around the complications in the game
what else is there let's say here and to
move rook F 1 this is mostly played and
now you need to remember this move very
powerful move attacking the rook on f1
you even give this year with check king
e7 and now black is black of the rook
down but you will get the f1 rook King
do you want me to prevent the mate and
move like this year can be answered very
very nicely with king d6 this doesn't
really give anything at the end White's
King will get executed it's not much you
can do
so kingly one here so it's the main move
then takes
then Bishop f5 now you can you can count
the material and see that it's actually
even after all this hacking it's an
image from a material point of view it's
an even position but black has got the
fast stronger tech going with e3 a
thread and whites a queen side isn't
playing at all let's say b3 check HERE
d3 what goes here you just push the
spawn and something like this for
instance and black is winning funny so
let's say d3 e2 Bishop d2 and you can
just promote here and have an extra
piece so at the end there should be 5
it's just a questionable move black will
get a very strong attack I think it's
it's really not playable for white but
you need to be yeah confident enough to
play this really and go into the
complications this can be somewhat funny
if you would get this in a blitz game or
really know if you forget if you've got
a really little time for this game like
a blitz game a bullet game or something
then okay just jump in and try your best
in the in the complications it's just
good for black if you played this in a
tournament game just go for it and take
your time in the in the messy positions
and try to figure it out you always need
to have the confidence that it is really
good for you and you just need to find
the right stuff it's just yeah I think
it's just not enough to play a
second-rate line here for instance that
could could play something like this and
it also has a fine position but this
doesn't have the same yeah the same
optimal result so to say which is almost
a win for black so B should be 5 as a
move you
look forward to if you would get it so
what else is there white usually tries
Queenie fall in this position has a
similar idea but of course it's not so
there was so weak in comparison because
the bishop hasn't left its position on
f1 Saudi takes if I was just just silly
now and here black has more than one
good line actually I'm recommending the
the easiest to play and this is the
somewhat atypical move f6 f6 just covers
the e5 pawn and therefore asks yeah
white the question watch what the Queen
is actually doing when they fall the
usual on continuation here is something
like we should be five you can also look
at taking on d5 now like just recaptures
and now let's say it was like deform a
thing to remember here is so to take
note of if white tries to develop his
bishop here then black has the very
disturbing move Queenie for check this
is useful to remember white of course
Kemp cannot interpose because Queen is
just hanging so after this check he
needs to do yeah do king move so King d1
and then for instance Bishop e6 and yeah
you see that this penny on the
fourth-ranked ass yeah very annoying to
say the least a possible line could be
d3 rook to e8 right here rook takes d3
and white can resign really a quick
accident it's just useful to remember
this check in response to something
moving to c4 it can even be a pawn in
some lines this check can be often very
very effective in yeah putting a spanner
in the works for whites positions
so d4 here would be would be normal and
then the move is Bishop d7 and this
highlights the problematic position of
whites Queen it's just yeah in a
somewhat precarious position in 94
already threatened and if white tries
something like you should be five now
note that on this move you have this
check again and then the discovery of
the night
so this check is useful this should be
five and then for instance eight six and
this is yeah really really already very
bad for white what can he do the bishop
is just hanging and on see for you have
this check again here and rock the eight
and yeah white is white is already
losing here
he doesn't have have four move really SP
five is hanging and he needs to play
something along this lines oops
not this one we captures of course and
then Queen moves somewhere and takes
only form black wins it's just one huge
chunk of material here so it's really
easy for y2 to get lost in this kind of
position where this was deform or
actually if this was taking taking here
while and the Bishop b5 is mostly played
I think the actually the best move here
but this is rarely played as yeah it's
some somewhat makes the whole wide setup
look somewhat absurd is d3
and then we're treating the Queen to c2
back and white is playing something like
reversed Philidor with yeah not even
extra tempo okay black has played f6
which is not ideal but you can just
develop your pieces here Bishop e6 and
then maybe Knight d7 to g6 c7 c8 v6
would be would be good
get the knight to some decent square
maybe to g6 is best and Bishop e7
castles and black is just fine his can
central control but this is maybe still
around evil white doesn't have any
direct problems which after Bishop b5
you might have you just cover this and I
g7 and if Y doesn't do anything special
he will need to surrender the bishop a
at some point because of the Cinna
configuration here of the pieces he
takes d5 25 would be normal and now yeah
what can you I do nothing nothing much
really if he cancels you have a form and
yeah this night doesn't have a good
square it can it can go to deform of
course but after this yeah white is in
trouble again what should he do Knight
takes d4 s2 threatened with a witch used
with a huge on positional advantage and
he doesn't have a good move really he
could exchange here
but now you've threatened a6 again
winning the bishop pair and black is
just yeah like it's just better here
what can you do
cathode sum is one possibility or deform
and after this you can also you can just
advance here with e4 and White has a
problem with the snart if he attacks the
Queen now you can just retreat
now the knight is hanging needs to move
and after this you just capture and have
an extra pawn so c4 is bad but after
let's say Knight here 25 this also
problem g2 is hanging what should white
play
he cannot kind of take here as this one
is just hanging and well after castles
wins an exchange
or yeah you can go something like this
really horrible move weakening all white
squares and this is yeah almost for sure
fatal in the long run as to the bishop
on b5 is most likely exchanged at some
point Bishop d7 now maybe or maybe we
should page three also possible Bishop
d7 I would would think with the idea of
a six and getting this Bishop black
heads just a clear ehem
so yeah the fancy on e so you can see
not really a an opening that should
scare you but well it's it certainly
useful to know d5 here and to have some
idea of the the technical complications
especially after Bishop b5 this somewhat
white line but it's it's just wait for
black if you play somewhat slow stuff
against the Pantheon e let's say instead
of d5 and move like 96
why place T for to take here this one
this I'm just showing this this briefly
something like this would be the would
be the yeah the position of the slow
approach but this is just a relatively
boring game well yeah like a sequel eyes
maybe but it's nothing special and as
you can see after d5 white has got lots
of opportunities to lose the game really
quickly so d5 from really a smooth you
should play I'm really glad that I
looked this up a couple of I don't think
I don't think one or two years ago I
studied this a bit and I'm really really
satisfied that I did this because when I
got the opening in blitz games I think I
want all of them quickly with the kind
of stuff I just showed
and it's just yeah this opening is
something where you should go into this
is something which I call a yeah
punishment mode try to to punish the
opponent opponent for what what he is
playing and do you have really good
chances to do this in the pantheon e if
Y displaying ambitiously he can always
play yeah very yeah
let's say solid passive moves but this
shouldn't scare you like I'm like I
mentioned Queen a4 f6 and now I move
like d3 or after d5 of course white
could go d3 as well but okay this is
just fine for black you don't need to
know any specific stuff here just
develop your piece of pieces it's a
reversed fini door so nothing to be
scared of but if white plays ambitiously
as I showed as I have shown we should be
5 or D plays Queen a4 and then try some
funny stuff then he will most likely get
punished yeah this was the Pantheon e in
the next video I'll do 9390 f6 and well
basically I'm not sure if I managed to
the whole four Knights maybe the four
Knights without the Scotch for Knights
I'm not sure but this will be the
subject for the next video or maybe and
I take two videos I'm not sure I think I
prefer now to to split this up more into
separate videos to prevent having lots
of 40 50 minute videos it's better to
have I think segments of 20 minutes 25
minutes to cover to cover one one
specific line or one specific opening
like a DTM yeah thanks for watching and
yeah let's hope someone plays the
Ponciano against you okay thanks for
watching and talk to you soon